hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen mod vorstellungen minecraft
und zwar der cube kraft modifikation die
quantenphysik hinzufügt und wisst ihr
was ich mich gerade eigentlich frage
warum verschwindet meine brücke
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen mod vorstellung von der
kraft modifikation die wurde mir von
richie rom in skype vorgeschlagen er
meinte hey guck dir das mal an und nicht
zu wo das ist die geilste mode die hier
in meinem ganzen leben irgendwie
entdeckt habe
ich saß gerade ungelogen von 23 uhr bis
10 45 also zwei stunden und 45 minuten
daran mich in diesem ort allein schon
rein zu lesen dass bisher noch kein
deutscher irgendwie vorgestellt hat und
die auch nur in the beast unleashed
glaube ich in einer bestimmten version
verfügbar ist und den hexen und ticket
auch einen bestimmten version und
allgemein halt nur englische tutorials
es gibt und davon nur ganz ganz wenige
und sehr sehr kompliziert erklärt
deswegen dachte ich dass ich mal was auf
deutsch dazu mache das auch die
deutschen dass eventuell ein bisschen
davon mitkriegen was das denn für eine
geile modifikation ist der typ da raus
gebracht hat also ihr seht schon hier
hier verändern sich ein paar blöcke hier
immer mal so wenn ich da so ein
hingucker nicht und jetzt denkt euch
bestimmt erst mal so hat es darf alles
was ist wenn ich hier den kopf und dann
wieder weg wenn ich da wieder hin dann
ist er auf einmal nicht mehr darum was
ist wenn ich da hin cook und dann kommt
ihr auf einmal wieder hierhin und dann
wieder da in dem moment ich blockiere da
gucke ich auf einmal dahin dass er sich
dann verändert aller dann aller dann ich
von hier hin da hinten ist auf einmal
der anderen andere farbe und blabla ein
anderer blog das ist halt einfach
quantenphysik beziehungsweise quanten
energie einfach kernspaltung mehr oder
weniger diese ihr wisst es bestimmt alle
kernspaltung beziehen wir wissen nicht
aber halt atome verformen bzw atome
reproduzieren oder irgendwie sowas
ich weiß auch nicht so genau ich bin ich
so gut und physik allerdings wird das
ganze hier halt in minecraft zu mehr
oder weniger tage stimmen nachgestellt
und ich würde sagen ich fange jetzt mal
ganz langsam an ich hab mich ein paar
notizen gemacht und wie gesagt
zweieinhalb stunden wenn es euch
wirklich gefällt wenn es euch wirklich
gefällt solche wenn euch solche matthäus
gefallen da will ich mich wirklich mag
ich freuen das ist ein klick und das
zeigt mir dass es euch gefällt und dass
ich eventuell mehr davon machen soll
also ich habe nicht viel mühe damit
gegeben darüber will ich mich echt
freuen ich meine müsste es nicht machen
aber es wird mir nicht weiterhelfen
sagen erst mal ganz langsam an und zwar
gibt es diese front quantum board also
quantum ärzte quanten ärzte die sind zu
finden ganz normal in höhlen und
redstone taucht 80 prozent auf
beispielsweise dieses quanto amore nur
viermal ist also sonne sonne
find rate zwischen redstone und diamant
mehr oder weniger kann man sagen die
können nur mit eisen spitzhacke oder
halt diamant spitzhacke abgebaut werden
also eisen spitzhacke oder besser nicht
wenn ihr mit mord pack spielt gibt es ja
auch noch was geht sagt rubin spitzhacke
saphir spitzhacke so was halt kann damit
auch abgebaut werden und ist drop drop
doch ungefähr so viel wie redstone gc
sowie gleiche drop rate sie immer so
drei vier manchmal fünf so also da wenn
ihr einen abort dann kriegt ihr nicht
nur ein sondern halt auch mehrere so
dass quantum ohr daraus wenn ihr das
dann irgendwie dass daraus werden nicht
kontrovers gedruckt sondern daraus wird
konnte um das gel gedopt sowie bei
redstone comeback ein rats terror aus
sondern redstone dass es ist auch
möglich in der kommenden version in der
version 1.0.1 dieser modifikation kraft
dass man mit einem red star dust und
lime green day also lieben grüner
hellgrüner farbstoff dass man dass sich
das selbst kräften kann das konto um das
allerdings auch nur wenn man das in den
einstellungen aktiviert und deaktiviert
hat wenn man die sind dass man diese
konnte mosley ich finde weil sonst wenn
die ganze konnten sich überhaupt nicht
möglich in minecraft das erstmal zu den
groben sachen dann kommen noch zu den
chorproben sachen und zwar besteht die
ganze modifikation aus drei
verschiedenen distanzen essence of
obsession essence of super position und
ist sense of entertainment das sind
schon die weiter formen dieser essenzen
grob gesagt essence of obsession ist
dieser essenz bestimmt die richtung
bestimmt den block aus der richtung in
der man diesen block sich anschaut
es hat super position ist es ist das
gleiche wie es sein job auf observation
allerdings ist es achsen abhängig das
heißt achsen abhängig betritt eine 50
prozent chance auf dass der block der
oben ist oder der block in der unten ist
auftritt was das ganze ist braucht jetzt
noch nicht verstehen das sage ich euch
gleich noch anhand von beispielen will
ich dann viel besser zu verstehen als
auf der website von diensten typen
allerdings ist halt auf englisch und
essence of end segment ist einfach dass
mehrere blöcke zusammenhängen die
irgendwie halt so gebaut wurden gut und
fangen wir mal ganz normal an essence of
obsession kräfte man dem mann vier
quantum das so in seinen ring tut mehr
oder weniger und dann kriegt man halt
essence of obsession
doch mal so ein neues dings das hier
sollte erstmal nicht beachten das ist
nun mal winter dann kriegt er dieses
essence of obsession das sind halt alles
so sachen die haben an sich noch keine
funktion dieser essenzen sondern das
sind nur inhaltsstoffe für die sachen
die man nachher braucht also das sind
nur inhalts blöcke die man für andere
kräften rezepte später braucht dann
haben wir hier essence of super position
da muss man hier an orten das ist egal
ob man das stelle ich war das jetzt so
das crafting feld ist egal ob ihr das so
gemacht und ihr könnt auch so machen
oder halt doch so oder so es halt
einfach ein leicht zu zeigen so einfach
wenn das crafting fällt es einfach so da
rein zusammen quadrat und bekommt
essence of super physischen und hier
quantum das und eine essenz
superposition und ihr bekommt essence of
intent sodass jetzt erstmal ganz grob
dazu gesagt jetzt kommen wir zum ob
server die pendel blog dass wir schon
gerade gesagt es kommt darauf an aus
welcher position man auf den block
schaut welcher erhält ist zu welchem er
sich verwandelt so jetzt erstmal ganz
grob gesagt ihr seht hier dass es oben
dass es unten das ist links das ist
rechts das ist und das ist nie das ist
das ist oben dass es unten
das ist norden das ist süden und das ist
west und das ist so jetzt denke ich erst
mal hat sollen dass ich habe hier in
observer dependent blog mir schon wenn
inventar gepackt dass es genau mit
diesem crafting rezept wir könnten jetzt
beispielsweise hier noch von obsidian
blocken tun und hier einen travel blog
dass es immer wenn wir weil das hier ab
ist also oben
aber wenn von oben drauf gucken ist es
ein obsidian block und im winter von
unten gucken ist dann ein gremmel blog
da wir das nicht haben
was soll da wir das nicht haben ist das
einfach kein blog wenn wir von ober- und
gucken habt ihr gehört ist es gar kein
blog er wird einfach wie luft angezeigt
wenn wir von oben drauf gucken wenn wir
allerdings kann von oben runter fliegen
von der seite darauf gucken ist es dann
zum beispiel ein blog auf gold blog auf
ihrem blog auf drei mit oder blog auf
cobblestone da sehen wir zum beispiel
daran ganz gut hier haben wir jetzt
einen blog auf gold wenn wir dahin
gucken wir allerdings ihren gehen von
hier gucken verwandeln wir sind die sich
und wir sehen nur hier ein blog und das
wissen ob sie ihren blog oder wenn wir
das so machen sehen wir zum beispiel da
nur hier ist dann auf einmal der gold
blog wenn wir das von hier guckt man auf
einmal nur hier also was das sie jetzt
brauche ich nicht interessieren erstmal
ich zeige euch das ganze mal anhand von
diesem blog hier den wir gerade schon
gekracht hatten oben gold und die ganzen
anderen sachen und ich platze den mach
einfach hier in der luft so hast du was
ich euch vorher noch zeigen könnte damit
ihr wenn ihr nur seinen blog habt
übrigens erst mal versteht
aus welcher richtung überhaupt was kommt
wo haben wir denn da hin was ihr seht
zum beispiel jetzt es hier jetzt ist
hier nix und jetzt ist noch mal nix
sehen wir hier diamant cobblestone gold
eisen oben unten diamant also er wird
immer angezeigt norf süden westen osten
oben nix unten nichts grünes immer so
diese diese veränderung dazwischen also
von verändert sich jetzt gerade von
eisen jetzt zunächst zunächst jetzt
wieder zu diamant also wenn hier und
obsidian hätten wir das zweite nichts
zum beispiel obsidian ich hoffe ihr
versteht das und ihr könnt noch
kommentare schreiben ich bin da echt
offen für alles das ist jetzt bleibt gut
stellt euch einfach vor da ist der block
wir gucken sind ungefähr auf einer höhe
mit dem blog sowie gucken ganz gut weg
kommen jetzt wieder hin und wir sehen
ein cobblestone da wir cobblestone unten
liegen hatten hatten wir glaube ich
heißt es dass wir gerade vom süden drauf
gucken wenn ich f3 drücke seht ihr okay
des norton aber wir gucken zum süden hin
also das gegenteil so wenn wir jetzt von
hier drauf gucken müsste es ja
eigentlich ein diamant blog seien unter
das ist ein diamant besteht zwar sehen
aber wir gucken in den norden
wir gucken in den süden aber der blog
zeigt im norden so meine ich das gut
wenn wir von hier drauf gucken kann es
jetzt halt entweder ein gold blog oder
eisen blogs ein ich weiß nicht genau wo
wir uns befinden wir gucken gerade in
austin das heißt wenn osten es müsste
eigentlich in eisen block sein
cook ist ein eisen blog so wenn jetzt
jeder block sind und wir gucken zum
beispiel im westen der block den rest
müsste es da links im westen ein gold
block lag müsste ist ein gold blocken es
wird ein gold blog wenn wir allerdings
jetzt von oben oder von unten also das
sind all diese sechs positionen eines
blogs will von uns oder von oben drauf
gucken dürfte der block nix anzeigen
dass wir gucken von unten und es ist nix
wir können vor mir das mal wieder von
hier drauf gucken
es ist wieder ein gold blog wir gucken
von oben und es ist wieder nix und wir
können hier auch als einfach durch
schweben wir können hier durch schweben
der blog ist weg ok jetzt hab ich grad
von der seite ein bisschen geguckt aber
der block war weg das ist auf jeden fall
hammergeil auf jeden fall schon mal
diese möglichkeit dass minecraft erkennt
aus welcher richtung man auf einen block
schaut
und allgemeinen diese ganze das ist
relativ leicht noch dargestellt wird für
uns verständlich na gut kommen wir
weiter dass es erstmal so der observer
dependent blog quantum blog ist mehr
oder weniger genau das gleiche wir haben
wir immer noch diese sechs positionen
ich habe das hier mal wieder offen
gelassen weil ich dachte das ist ein
bisschen zu schwer bin ich euch das so
zeige nach oben und unten mit zu
berücksichtigen
deswegen wenn wir das freie das ist es
halt einfach freie seht frei frei
cobblestone kommission habe ich jetzt
oben unten kommission dann links rechts
und frei frei also oben unten
cobblestone links gold und rechts
diamant dann haben wir hier einen
quantum blog warum habe ich den ich
zeige euch dass man einfach wieder genau
hier wo wir und das wohin auch gezeigt
haben so schaut euch diesen blog jetzt
an so wenn wir von hier drauf gucken
sehen wir einen gold blog würden wir nun
weg gruppen würden wieder drauf gucken
wir würden bei einem blog bei einem ob
service die pendent blog liest er glaube
ich den ich euch vorhin gezeigt habt wo
man wo es richtung abhängig ist von wo
man drauf schaut mein gott wir haben
schon wie kurkuma wie oft ich mich wie
oft ich wieder tag und so gemacht hab
einfach nur in der vorbereitung also
werde ich die ganze zeit ich habe auf
übels of skate gedrückt aber die ganze
zeit wo ich etwas ausprobiert habe habe
ich immer die ganzen tage und nächte
durchgespielt dazu so hier haben wir
gold
und wir haben jetzt wieder wo wir haben
jetzt wieder zu und entwickelt sich doch
das ist jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen
verbuggt sowie von hier drauf gucken
acom es jetzt ernst geht das jetzt
gerade gar nicht mehr
doch jetzt gehts cobblestone cobblestone
kann sich nicht verändern weil wir haben
oben und unten cobblestone gemacht so
wenn wir von hier drauf gucken haben wir
nur 50 prozent schon dass es entweder
gold oder halt also entweder diamant
oder gold oder wie hat wieder diamant
oder wieder gold also es geht halt drei
mal das gleiche von hier halt auch von
hier so gold
ich glaube ihr habt verstand also es
hätten 50-chance
das heißt ich kann ich sagen wenn ich
jetzt blocken stelle und ich gucke jetzt
hin kann ich euch nicht sagen ob das
jetzt kann auch wenn es ihr jetzt kommt
es zum beispiel ich kann euch jetzt
nicht sagen ob das gold oder diamant
wird beispiel es wird zum beispiel gold
es kann allerdings auch jetzt setzt der
männchen hinsetze noch mal drauf drücke
das halt diamant wird also es ist halt
nur 50 prozent chance dass es
irgendetwas davon mehr oder weniger halt
gibt so das war der quantum blanc kann
sich der blog für ihn ist übrigens
observer die pending blog so kombi nun
zu dem phantom goggles die sind ein
bisschen einfacher und zwar einfach glas
payne glas payne und quantum das in der
mitte und ihr bekommt die quantum
gorbitz goggles damit seht ihr zum
beispiel das könnt ihr euch einfach hier
drauf packen dann sieht man hier so
super stylisch aus wie ich halte sich
für cool aus männern
screenshot damit sieht man halt so grüne
da sieht man alle blöcke die ihnen wie
veränderbar sind weil wenn ich die zum
beispiel jetzt absätze seht ihr ich sehe
hier goldberg und obsidian blöcke das
ist sehr gut und zwar wenn ich dann
irgendwelche wenn ich hab mir
aufgeschrieben als notizen man sieht
alle quantum blöcke und kann verborgene
fallen beispielsweise erkennen auch
möglich sind rätsel also es kann sein
dass wenn man ihr seht hier alle blöcke
die irgendwas mit quantum zu tun haben
werden mir so als leuchtend angezeigt
werden sie gar keiner veränderung
das ist besonders cool einerseits wenn
man zum beispiel in wie das mal
irgendwie so ausgebaut dass es auf
servern oder auf online servern und wann
spitze will games dann kann man sich
diese konto bild kriegt man dann
irgendwo dann erkennt man schon fallen
die eventuell von anderen spielern
gebaut wurden also hunger games sowie
games es sowas nicht möglich in der
kurzen zeit aber hunger games kinder
teilweise eine stunde oder so da ist das
schon möglich dass man dann einfach so
fallen erkennt damit allerdings ist bei
hunger games beispielsweise könnte es
dann möglich sein dass in den maps drin
wenn sich dass diese mod irgendwann so
etabliert hat das in den maps drin schon
quantum sachen gebaut werden konnte um
rätsel wo für meine quantum gockel
brauchen also eine konto brille um
dieses rätsel rauszubekommen
das heißt man kann es quasi nur lösen
indem man dann hier sieht und die blöcke
sind so und so die muss dann so
verstellen blabla dann habe ich
geschafft bei wenig diese konnten bockel
nicht hätte will ich zum beispiel das
einfach als gold erkennen
ihr denkt jetzt wahrscheinlich ohne um
alle welt gold das muss ja etwas
besonders sein ja klar denn man kann es
natürlich auch einfach zu corbis tor
machen oder auch zu gras es kann doch
einfach im gras block sein es kann auch
im boden drin stehen dann sind sie auf
einmal meine konten google aus und sehe
hier ist und coating die im boden drin
dass sich halt nur durch das konto
gesehen
also das sind so die funktion der
quantum gockel dann kommen wir zu den
enthält blogs und zwar können die haben
die möglichkeit dass die überall in der
welt platziert werden können
egal wie man guckt also es muss halt es
wird halt egal wie man guckt das ist die
gleiche reaktion das wird allerdings
erst ab version 1.0.1 dem motto
hinzugefügt also habe ich noch kein
beispiel was ich zeigen kann man braucht
dafür zwei observer die pendent blog
beispielsweise und einen essence of
obsession also ob server die panel und
essence of obsession muss schon das
gleiche sein und dann kann ich zum
beispiel wenn ich hier einen blog
hinsetzen von observer observer von
observer dependent block und irgendwo
ganz anders dann werde ich dann da drauf
gucke verändert er sich da hinten halt
auch das ist halt das crafting rezept
dafür
und jetzt wo ich kann es nicht glauben
dass wir schon da sind und wie dass wir
es hier sind und wir haben schon 14
minuten durch
aber ich hoffe dass alle die noch da
sind schreibt man alle wenn ihr gerade
noch da sein
ich gucke das immer ganz gern so wie
viele wirklich so bist du der minute
geguckt haben schreibt dann bitte in die
kommentare
hashtag bestem ottawa schreibt dass man
in die kommentare
da muss ich also ein rücksetzer unter
drücken schreibt dass man die kommentare
hashtag beste model war irgendwie sowas
in die richtung damit sehe dass sie
jetzt gerade noch dran sein weil es war
bisher echt starke sachen die ich
gezeigt habe also nicht stark von mir
rüber gebracht sondern stark zum
aufnehmen als zuschauer das vermute ich
schon etwas zu wir brauchen sieben tanks
in der formation einer hose angeordnet
da wo die eier und schaukeln ein quantum
das und darunter ein glas payne so dann
bekommen wir ein quantencomputer dieser
quantencomputer ist an sich erst mal
wenn ich den irgendwo hinsetzen hier
beispielsweise mal hier oben ich möchte
ich meinen schönen schnee kaputt machen
steht hier frame incomplete warum weil
ich da noch keine diese von diese
dauernde umgebaut habe diesen tank bzw
diesen bereich abdecken der teleportiert
werden soll und da komme ich dazu und
was wenn ich diesen bereich hätte
allerdings keinen eisblock dann wird
hier stehen inzwischen tooling dieses
inzwischen cooling heißt es da kein
eisblock daneben ist was heißt dass
eisblock was heißt dass eisblock blabla
luca zeige ich euch jetzt also erstmal
so kräfte die auf diesem konto computer
mich ja gerade schon gezeigt davon
gibt's auch wieder intel konnten
computer ihr wisst bescheid können auch
irgendwo anders in der welt stehen
und jetzt kommen wir zu einem gewissen
beispiel
wir brauchen erstmal damit ihr seht wie
man sich also erstmal dieser
quantencomputer ist der ist ist erstmal
der nur der bestandteil der
quantifizierung des teleportation
systems was ich euch gleich zeigen wer
die wirklichen teleportation system
zeigen kritisieren ist mehr oder weniger
spielt damit rein conti sieht es halt so
mehr oder weniger und die enthält
bürocomputer hält das genau das gleiche
an dem ich habe hier aufgeschrieben
es ist wie enthält blogs auch gleiche
eigenschaft obgleich lokal anderer
standort also die haben die gleiche
eigenschaft zwei verschiedene computer
obwohl es ein anderer standort dass ich
noch mal wieder times hätten null so
quantifizierung teleportation ist nutzt
die kraft von quantencomputern um eine
region der minecraft welt zu
digitalisieren
also dieser content computer
digitalisiert jetzt diesen bereich der
hier abgesteckte das sind hier 77 blöcke
weil ich hier immer drei blöcke abstand
gelassen habe zu diesen teilen hier
dieses teil kann beispielsweise auch
hier stehen also das muss kein quadrat
sein das kann auch ein quader sein
dieser bereich wird dann halt
digitalisiert und in minecraft mehr oder
weniger darum teleportiert diesem
bereich kann er entweder kopiert werden
das ist eine quantifizierung oder der
kann auch teleportiert werden das ist
der teleportation ich werde euch jetzt
die teleportation zeigen quantifizierung
ist die vorstufe davon ich zeige euch
jetzt direkt die teleportation dachte
ich mir und zwar haben wir hier diese
diesen computer so diesen computer wie
gesagt habe ich euch ja schon gezeigt
wie man sich den kräften und jetzt
brauchen wir halt erstmal diese vier
blöcke ihr seht wenn ich meine konten
global drauf setzte hier sind diese
diese müsste ich übrigens nicht beachten
diesen scheiß egal als erst mal für euch
ihr brot wir brauchen hier vier
verschiedene und was man auch sehen kann
der zuschauer schon bemerkt
wenn ich mich hier auf diesen links
drauf stelle und darüber gucke oder
sagen wir mal ich stelle mich hier hin
und schaue darüber ist nur der nur der
aus der richtung des computers ist nur
der gold wenn ich zb aus dieser richtung
gucke ist nur der gold wenn ich aus
dieser richtung gucke ist nur der yaris
ist blutig muss immer so ein bisschen
garten komplett weit weg gucken dann ist
nur der gold und wenn ich aus dieser
richtung gucke vorwärts erraten ist nur
da hinten gut also wenn man aus der
richtung des teleporter sie guckt muss
jeder gold sein
das heißt ich bin hier drauf und jeder
in denen ich hingucke der ist gold also
wie gesagt auf die da hinten nicht
konzentrieren der hier ist nur der
gleich der hier ist der gleiche wie der
hier deswegen wird er auf gold jeder
muss aus der richtung halt auch ein
goldener block dann sein also ich wäre
jetzt an wenn ihr ein anderes kräftige
rezept hat ist natürlich klar jetzt
fragt euch hin welches crafting rezept
ganz einfach ihr braucht observer die
pendent blogs und zwar wenn ihr
teleportation system machen wollt
braucht ihr nicht nur diese vier sondern
ihr braucht noch mal vier weil das
gleiche müsst ihr noch einmal nachbauen
in einer anderen an einem anderen ort
das heißt lasst euch nicht beirren hier
zieht ihm erst mal seine linie weil die
s hier unten an nichts zu tun mit dem
hier oben ist wisst ja noch vom vom
observer blog oben unten norden süden
westen osten
hier haben wir zum beispiel im osten
blog auf gold hier haben wir im süden
hier haben was im westen und im norden
davon haben wir hier 2 4 2 4 2 und 4 2
so wenn ihr dann soweit seit es ihr vom
norden süden westen und osten jeweils
zwei observer dependent blogs habt dann
braucht ihr noch so viel obsidian wir in
die höhe gehen wollt beziehungsweise
könnte erst hier alles auf irgendwo
mitten rein setzen mitten in die tiefe
und dann braucht ihr noch ein glas der
das da oben absteckt der da oben jetzt
sind cup darauf macht das heißt die
diese fläche hier auf dieser ebene bis
hier unten kann kopiert werden wir so
teleportiert so ihr stellt an den
quantencomputer der mitte wie gesagt
diese teile dass die den angucken
ihr könnt ihr euch immer überlegen ich
würde zum beispiel nicht alles auf
einmal kräften sondern erst zum beispiel
das ganze im ja es ist hier das wäre zum
beispiel sorgen süden westen dass er zb
osten nehmt ihr den osten block dann
drückt die f3 wenn ihr den tipp den
computer gesetzt habt und guckt dann von
hier aus in austin und dann seht ihr das
hier ist mein osten blog hier zb gold
links so
also am besten wenn ich da hingucke
stimmt ist die besten ich hoffe ihr
wisst was mit also es muss halt nach so
sei eines der konten computer damit
besteht und ringsherum hält alles dann
in der farbe wie ihr das halt als
einziges nicht gemacht habt in im
kräftig tablet nicht was nicht die
hauptfarbe ist im kräftig table
jetzt brauchen wir allerdings noch eine
kühlung hierfür und dazu nimmt man
einfach es muss einfach ein eis daneben
stellen und dann ist die kühlung mehr
oder weniger vollendet und dann können
wir hier einfach auf energies klicken
allerdings wird das zurzeit nichts
bringen da wir hier nicht stehen haben
hier können jetzt einfach mal was
hinstellen verstehe ich jetzt einfach
mal dass hierhin hat ja noch ein
bisschen variation mäßiger bauen hier so
bauen wir das mal so und jetzt können
wir ein richtig aufmachen und of energy
ist denkt ihr euch bestimmt
[ __ ] warum ist sie auf einmal schnee und
warum ist die glas ganz einfach fliegen
wir doch einfach mal hier rüber wo ich
das ganze natürlich schon aufgebaut habe
und hier sind wir hier sind jetzt am
start wo ich das ganze jetzt gerade
aufgebaut habe warum die birke hier
nicht da als weiß ich gar nicht
ich könnte jedenfalls hier wieder auf
einer jazz klicken und dann würde ich
hier wieder das glas bekommen und jetzt
schauen wir mal was da hinten ist das
würde mich nicht wundern ist dahin jetzt
da hinten müsste jetzt theoretisch
eigentlich des dings sein
die heißt es ja auch das glas moment war
das ist das sollte eigentlich nicht so
sein ich mache das manchmal ganz kurz so
machen wir mal einfach eigentlich müsste
das bis werden so wir haben jetzt hier
kommt das lasse ich erst mache erstmal
gar nicht ich mache jetzt mal schnee der
ist gekühlt und den könnte ich
entscheiden so der es gefühlt
jetzt fliegen wir mal ganz kurz hierüber
kann auch sein dass daran lag dass ich
hier hinten noch vom test wohin die
pumpkins stehen hatte so jetzt machen
wir das immer ganz gut weg also dieser
bereich muss auf einer höhe seien ihr
seht schon höhe 65 ist am start da
hinten auch und es ist auch genau hier
drei entfernungen
das heißt wenn ich auf energies clique
müsste ich jetzt eigentlich wieso kommt
der zion kommt der denn her habe ich das
grad kopiert oder also eigentlich wenn
der jetzt hier ist und was was passiert
wenn jetzt wieder auf eine just click
jetzt ist er wieder weg
es ist ja wieder hier okay wenn ich
jetzt hier hinten hinfliegen mal wieder
das blöd dass ich das so weit weg
auseinander gemacht habe im test hat
zwei hin alles funktioniert und hier
hinten dass batmans komischen hier ist
gar nichts das heißt der theoretisch ich
klicke hier drauf und jetzt ist er
wieder hier warte und jetzt nochmal und
hier ist nichts normal und jetzt ist er
wieder hier
jetzt ist wieder weg also ihr seht schon
ist funktioniert aber ich habe mich
gerade warum die pumpkins c nicht
rüberkommen okay was ich durchmache dich
jetzt mal einfach weg
rogers und es passiert nichts es
passiert gar nichts
wie grace is das denn oder hab ich
irgendwo anders noch was komisches
gebaut
kann auch sein naja ich hoffe ich konnte
euch ein bisschen näher bringen es jetzt
komisch dass es ihr gar nicht
funktioniert kann auch seine sich gleich
einmal einfach aufschlagen musste dann
funktioniert wieder
aber eigentlich sollte alles klappen ich
mache mir die kühlung weg und macht den
teleporter noch mal weg so ich gebe mal
eis ein
jetzt habe ich hier die auskühlung so
energies der ist jetzt weg jetzt jetzt
ist nämlich auch das cooling weg bei
jetzt müsste eigentlich da ganz hinten
es angekommen sein
die pumpkins weil die kühlung ja weg ist
allerdings sind die nicht da verstehe
ich nicht verstehe ich kann wirklich
nicht
eigentlich müsste das hier passiert nix
hier ist nur der schnee halt weg und bei
da hinten kommt auch kein schnee an also
ihnen die sind die noch nicht
miteinander verbunden ich weiß nicht
woran es liegt da hinten hat sich jetzt
überhaupt irgendwas verändert es kommt
mir so vor als hätte ich einfach ein
copy system gebaut weil bei der kopie
ist es so wenn ich jetzt drauf clique
sind hier einfach die pumpkins wieder da
weil ich das jetzt quasi kopiert habe
quasi ich drücke drauf habe es kopiert
und ich kann sich einfach wieder
einfügen
nur auch hettich hat das ja hinten ich
konnte es seien ja auch nicht einfügen
und wenn man teleportieren will heißt es
halt dass man hier etwas hat dann drückt
man auf energies und dann kommt da
hinten raus und wenn man da hinten zum
beispiel diese konstruktion aus den
birken die ich hatte
und hier diese konstruktion aus den
pumpkins und dann klicke ich darauf
ändert es dann wären die halt getauscht
eigentlich kann auch sein dass die
entfernung noch ein bisschen zu groß ist
wie gesagt die mod ist gerade noch in
der mache ist in der version 1.0.0 1.00
also eine alpha noch und es sind auf
jeden fall schon echt geile sachen
hinzugefügt und man kann auch echt geile
sachen damit machen zum beispiel das was
ich schon formen intro gesehen habt
meine pre intro szene habe ich zb mit
dieser modifikation gemacht und das ist
einfach so ein cooler beweist für
irgendwelche feilen die gebracht werden
bauen die die man machen kann zum
beispiel stellt euch vor ihr lauft über
eine brücke er dreht euch um die brücke
ist einfach weg wegen dem quantum
observer observation dependent blog oder
könnt ihr da nicht mehr drüber laufen
aus der opposition sondern ihr könnt
quasi nur über die brücke einmal
überlaufen und aus das schön kann man
jetzt schneidet sie noch zum ende
das sind jetzt 25 minuten oder sogar
noch ein bisschen mehr und ich würde
sagen leute wenn es euch gefallen ich
würde mich echt dimensionen daumen hoch
freut mich dass jetzt drei stunden drei
stunden und 9 minuten bisher an dieser
mod die irgendwie vorzubereiten jetzt
muss ich jetzt ganz noch rändern rändern
bearbeiten schnell hochladen ezb sitzt
locker zwölf stunden an dieser richtig
richtig geilen motto einem solchen
motzen es mir wirklich wer diesen hammer
geil
schreibt mir einfach in die kommentare
ob wir mehr von solchen mods haben
wollte und dann würde ich sagen es euch
gefallen hat halt wie gesagt ihr wisst
was ihr tun solltet um mich glücklich zu
machen und ich meine stimme ist so maier
und hört auch schon und es ist einfach
nur hammer geil was in minecraft
mittlerweile alles möglich ist also man
sollte ich echt bedanken dafür dass das
spiel nur noch 20 euro kostet das spiel
noch 20 euro kostet wäre locker 50 60 70
euro wert mittlerweile bei den ganzen
möglichkeiten gegeben sind
na gut ich würde sagen es war ein
schöner tag